the Biden Administration is now wielding
the doj to double down on transiting the
kids Joe Biden's doj is challenging the
Tennessee law that says you can't cast
straight little kids and pump them full
across sex hormones you can't trans
vulnerable children Biden's doj says oh
yes you will we are not going to let the
people of Tennessee through their
elected representatives stop the
transiting of the kids we are going to
challenge the Tennessee law that bans
what the White House calls critically
medically necessary care for transgender
youth forget about transiting the kids
for a second forget about the whole
ideology of transgenderism just think
about what this says about
self-government the only conclusion here
that we can draw is that this White
House and the whole political class that
it represents they don't feel they need
to answer to the people